the world peace game is a four foot by
four foot by four foot Plexiglas
towering structure it's basically a
geopolitical simulation that my group of
students from nine years old I usually
teach the elementary school but up to
high school and even young adult they
play around this gigantic structure to
solve 50 interlocking world problems
that I've given them a 13-page crisis
document they're trying to solve it
while reading soon's is the art of war
and trying to do this problem-solving
without combat if possible they also
have to raise the asset value of every
country involved in the game which is
almost impossible to do I've designed it
so that the game actually fails
massively at first it has to because
that's like life life is full of success
and failure and so we've got to put
everything in so students can learn to
deal with and manage everything that
happens in a safe and appropriate way
that's essentially the game on four
levels undersea ground and sea aircraft
and outer space emulating our planet and
there to solve all the problems of the
world in about eight weeks a lot of
people do wonder can 4th graders can
elementary school children handle
complex problem-solving and we might
think not because they just simply
haven't been here long enough but my
approach is the opposite actually I
believe having experienced their wisdom
their insight and their kindness that
they seem to be able to do so much more
than we give them credit for or even
imagine they can so in the world peace
game I don't preach you or break down
things into bite-sized pieces you know
so their little minds can handle it I
believe they have great minds and huge
hearts and so I actually over complexify
I can add so many complex issues
together at once it's a real overload
situation and the idea is designed to
overload that left brain thinking that
the intellectual analytical thinking so
that it collapses and then they have to
use that intuitive side they have to
reach deeper into themselves through
critical sink thinking and creative
thinking and think thoughts and
techniques and methods that have never
been thought of
for because the conventions don't work
so I've designed the system to destroy
the conventional approaches and then
they're thrown back on themselves
they've got to dig deeper to find the
meaning and answer within themselves and
they do that collaboratively and they
discover collaboration in the process
what these children have shown me is
different from what I originally
intended when I first invented this game
in 1978 with inner-city high school
youth it was a game just about one
subject area about Africa and I taught
to the children's passion which was
board games at the time and I put in
some problem-solving started like that
and I thought I was teaching content
information simple problem-solving
that's all I was interested in that's
what I thought you were supposed to do
but as a teacher my practice has been
informed by the evolutionary thinking
the astounding thinking of my students
over time they have shown me that the
purpose the real purpose of things like
this is becoming a beautiful wonderful
human being they say that the game is
about compassion mr. hunter the game is
really about taking care of everybody
not leaving anybody out I didn't know
that when I made the game but that's
what they come to that's what they
arrive at that's what they devise they
every time we play the game they leave
no one out they make certain that the
game is won by everybody increasing in
their interest in their resources in
their value and so this idea of
increasing compassion and decreasing
suffering in the world is what 9 year
olds are showing me is the way to go and
they do it every time we play the game
decades in it we've had some odd
personalities some interesting people
some we've had some bullies sometimes
but the game the collective wisdom of
the group tends to bring them to a
different place so that gives me a great
optimism really a great hope and these
things that they've taught me are
actually deeper lessons and I hope they
teach others as they get
you